so when I was about four five my mother
took to see Bambi in the cinema because
they were showing you obviously camera
in the forties but they were showing it
at a cinema near us and I already had it
on VHS and I during drip drip drop
little April showers I I marched down
the aisle and sang it for everyone at
the Front's of the cinema Lion King but
my dad says when the lights went down
for cities he's called Darby O'Gill and
the little people knew about this
leprechaun man who used to there was
like a banshee I think the first early
memory I had was I think I was way too
young to see it but I went to see Love
Actually I'm ever be completely
terrified and crying my eyes out I
remember I watch this movie called
invitation of life is from like the 50's
the intricate Italian morning matinees
and watch the serials and Flash Gordon
and the Durango kid things like that I
remember when I was 7 years old my dad
bought me the sound of music
and he probably the VHS tapes it was
thought like to DHS's and it was one of
my favorite films growing up I was
visiting my sister in
para cenar in 1979 I like to publish now
in 72 you know it was coming into our
own like this you know older black woman
trying to navigate the relationship
between the two daughters you know it's
just like something so powerful and that
was like the personal guess I was like
oh my god I could cry you know watching
movie it was so new so powerful Miss
Mary
[Music]
[Music]